Here we have the comma bird.
It sits on the line in the middle of a sentence and takes a little rest.
So, when do you use a comma bird?
When you want to add some extra information to a sentence, you separate it with a comma.
It lets you take a little rest and breathe before going on.
The different parts of the sentence are called a clause.
Here is a sentence with two parts, two clauses.
My friends and I were hungry, so we ate an amazing pizza.
Ideas are linked together with a comma.
Comma birds are also used to list things.
The pizza had cheese, olives, pepperoni, ham and pineapple.
But too many comma birds will be too heavy on the line.
Never use a comma when you can use a period.